because of social media has a comedian
now had more
influence than they did 30 years ago so
go back 30 years ago who was the face 30
years ago eddie who was the okay eddie
murphy george carla and george collins
my favorite crown me too and he
progressed yeah
richard what would you say they had the
same amount of influence if not more
than today or is today's top like like
take today chappelle yeah does chappelle
have more influence today than eddie
murphy in the 90s um i do think he does
because
but but again
entertainment uh has been so atomized
you know i mean
social media is about getting your
attention there are so many different
avenues you're competing with so many
different ways to
and i i think that think about this for
a second like music let's just take
music music has become more of a
consumption it's become something that
you would digest you you listen to
while you're driving and then you're
waiting for the next tune it's so now
you've got dojo cab you've got these
different people that have you know good
for you knowing the the hits yeah yeah
yeah you know i'm young but but um
i i i don't know that
i don't know that
any musical group maybe kanye is an
exception i don't know but
like the influence or the impact
something like led zeppelin had
um or lenny bruce had or uh george
carlin had when
when the collective
mind was focused on four channels there
wasn't that much expression you had to
also earn
you had to earn so much of of
the experience you had to wait
for that right time turn the tv on you
couldn't miss it hurry up hurry up it's
starting you know it was that it was
happening there was no recording or
anything so when you watched it you got
to watch it once usually and it had such
an impact on you what's the what's the
tyler what is that art did we read that
article a couple months ago or maybe i
read this where it said as popular as
tucker is today
50 years ago there was a personality in
u.s that had you know 75 million
listeners on a daily basis because there
was only four channels did you did you
do that
i'll give you an example
in 2001 2000 i was doing a tv show
um i think it was 2000 2001 to whatever
it was and uh inside schwartz
when i was doing the goldbergs that was
a hit for abc was the biggest show nbc i
think maybe six million people would
listen watch it that's that was their
number one i think
uh it was the goldbergs were just so so
that was yeah that was six million
people okay i did that show for almost
seven years then i did a spin-off with
my character when we probably got
five and a half six million people that
was a big deal that was a hit
right
when i did in
2001 or two i did a show called inside
schwartz which was getting i think 15
million 15.5 million people to watch
maybe more we got cancelled because it
wasn't enough yeah right wow so back 15
minutes oh yeah dude because
friends and
will and grace were getting you know 25
30. so it it that just wasn't enough for
the network they were like oh no we got
other shows so that's how we were so we
were so
focused on one thing
and that's the that's the biggest
challenge i think in many ways for us as
a society even think about how
christianity in the united states was
almost like
the focal point of our ethics our
morality our justice system the way we
related to each other in god we trust
you said prayers in school that was
never controversial even though there
was this notion of separation of church
and state it was still a christian
nation quote unquote
try saying that now so so now we they're
just there's no fixed point of truth i
think there's no fixed point of
attention and that comes with great
things but also its own challenges so to
pat's question
that was a long way no i think i think
you're saying that basically
30 years ago the top comedian or the top
voice or whether it's the walter
cronkites of the world did have a bigger
voice i mean think about it if in the
90s how honored would you be to go on
johnny carson oh my god did you ever go
it would change your whole life yeah
i did letterman overnight dude yeah if
you go on jimmy kimmel today does anyone
give to you no no no it does nothing for
yourself
yeah that's the point yeah i so i but i
do think that having said that
the the world is also pretty polarized
so it might be atomized but it's also
polar we got teams man we got wokestan
we got trumpistan and then we got a lot
of us in the middle who are kind of like
hey dude i'm i'm not with this insane
this gender nazis i don't even know what
they're talking about i just want to i
believe in the free market i like to own
my guns but i don't want spree shooters
we you know most of us are kind of like
trying to get life and i i think when
you have a guy like dave chappelle
who comes along and says
hey man i'm all for equality i'm a black
guy i get it
you guys are crazy
and then you get a you get a small
pocket of those people who are like
they're not interested in equality
they're just like how dare you and
everything else
you know so it may seem like he's but he
has influence he's he's who we're
talking about why because he took on the
transgender thing right so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]